hello my name is mathias from datatec
and in this video I want to show you
how to calculate a manager test data tab directly
online first of all
what is a one way newcast with the
menuett it can be tested whether there is
a difference between two groups
, for example whether  there is a
difference between the reaction time
for women and the reaction time for
men to determine this difference
, ranks are used instead of the actual values, i.e. the
actual values
are not
used but the
ranks formed are used
to calculate the mcnew test, which includes the
manual test  to the non-
parametric test and is therefore the
opposite of the test for independent
stands for what is special is that it is subject to
fewer strict
requirements than the offender is therefore
the human being nude asthma is
used when the requirements for
the offender are not met
so what are  now the prerequisite
for men your test to calculate a real test
, only two
independent line drills with original
scaled characteristics
must be available the variables do not
have to fulfill a distribution crank so it does not have to
present a normal distribution
okay now we calculate because if you use
geo test online with data for
this we have to  first of all the
table
dr now you can copy your own data
here
i have prepared a small example here for a
change where you examine this
difference between the reaction
times of men and women
copy this data now simply date up in the table
too click on offender's square
test and hannover now i
just need to select reaction time women and
reaction time men and
then i only need to
determine whether it is about independent
random samples or independent random samples
in our case it is
about independent random samples and whether I want
a parametric test berec  we want
a non-parametric we do
n't want a metric test
then I get the
results for the man with new test I
get the ranks from the groups
of the pony variable reaction time
women and reaction time men the
middle middle rank and the slow
and  in this table i get the
stats for the nude is we see
that the p value is 0.86 2 so it
is greater than the significant level
of 0.05 so there is no
significant difference between the
two groups i.e. the
reaction time of women  below
response time from men
thanks a lot and if you have any questions
just leave me a comment goodbye